so yeah it's about time and we're in a
time loop so let's see how this works
out this time if I ask again now who
would know what this actually means so
lift your hands I mean I know that at
least half of you are lying now ah see
okay so and the other half so everybody
should know what this means right and I
mean the first thing is the millisecond
since the epoch until actually right now
and it's probably the standard way
computers represent time and second one
is more the way that humans represent
time and well in essence the talk is
about how to get from the second to the
first before I start a few disclaimers
I'm still not a linguist yeah so I don't
know I mean linguist for sure know a lot
about time physicists know a lot about
time sociologists probably also know a
lot about time meanings of time the
Eternity whatever I'm rather an engineer
so I have a very practical approach here
because I had a problem to solve and I
couldn't find anything to solve it and
that was my way to solve it but we use
time a lot as humans and well I mean one
thing that probably differentiates us
from a lot of other species is that we
can actually reason about time about the
past the future things like that and
then if you have kids you know that at
least my kids that took a very long time
to realize what time actually means -
you get the chocolate later whatever
no no movies before 6:00 well and then
like humans communicate about time it's
also it's more often than not it's very
ambiguous right for next Sunday
later after lunch it's not very well
defined it is not as well defined as a
second sensory fog still I mean to
communicate with the machines using
natural language for humans is a very
convenient thing to do and maybe I'm
wrong but if you read the media then
but machine voice interfaces are
becoming more popular and at least the
likes as Amazon and Apple and Google
seems strongly to believe that we will
talk with our computers in the future
instead of using a keyboard and then
regardless of the mode of how we
communicate whether we type the text or
we as I actually talk to the computer if
the computer is meant to understand that
I want to book a table at a restaurant
tomorrow evening he someone needs to
understand what I mean was tomorrow
evening so then like if the machine is
supposed to understand time that to
challenges obviously the first one is it
has to understand which parts of the
language actually relate to time
expressions and the second bit it needs
to interpret these parts make sense of
them and also in the context and city
paths as well as a library that's
basically a practical approach to solve
the second problem too well interpret
time expressions it's also not getting
too much detail here it's opinionated
about how to it's time and to my
company's use case which is that we we
get messages from customers it's about
in travel booking and then if they it's
very rarely that they reason about the
past was us right they rather reason
about the future and usually their
reason about the near future the
structure of my talk it's basically two
parts the first part is the warm up like
some background some motivation and
should be comprehended by the second
part is about details technical details
inside the package how it actually works
might be a bit confusing but I hope not
too much confusing well my son has a
programming language like every
programming language actually has means
to handle time and like this RC format
here is probably amongst the most common
ones I guess everybody's seen that
before
and in Python we have the day time
modules we have things like time states
date times time deltas and also some
more advanced packages to deal with
relative times and
like that like two days in the future
one minute in the past
there are also some packages to pass
well they'll form time expressions like
the date you till date parser if you
posit a well formatted time string and
basically any language it will be able
to transform it into the time date/time
object and well there are actually very
few at least maintained packages that
are able to pass less than are formed
things so things that do not like form
the time description there's past day
time it's only in English Chrono Pisan
slightly outdated yeah and then finally
there are some rappers - standard NLP
tools and like su time from Stanford
what is that this is basically regular
expression based only works in English
and a it's very hard to get that running
there's a Python wrapper for that but at
least for me it crashes after five tries
and then you have to restart Python
which is no fun and if you want to
extend it well it's Java so I don't know
and then another thing they are insulted
it's called duckling and itself they
themselves say it's a language engine
and tooling for expressing testing and
evaluating composable language rules on
input strings and especially also on
times but that's written in Haskell
which is much nicer than Java but still
yeah it's hard to extend but because it
works actually pretty well this is
basically the blueprint for a CT pass
and then maybe someone will yell at me
now but actually I'm not aware of any
other packages that do this job
reasonably well which is kind of
surprising because it's pretty common so
what do we want to achieve in the end of
course we we want something that's able
to pass well-formed expressions so like
properly formatted dates should be
understood and then there are named
expressions Monday now tomorrow the end
of months we want to understand time
ranges in simpler or more complex
configurations and then of
like combinations of all of that like
next Sunday evening after 6:00 and as I
mentioned you can use regular
expressions and it's actually the
regular expressions makes sense because
time expressions have many formalities
even if it's if it's a natural language
more often than not there are very
formal bits and that's if it's formal
it's a dealer for regal to do regular
expressions and like the regular
expression here would match anything
that describes a numerical day right
anything that's from 0 to 31 probably
with zero in front of it or not and like
like a small detour for the computer
scientists their regular expressions the
expressive power is Type three languages
and formally it's like you always have a
non-terminal symbol that you can
translate into a terminal followed by a
non-terminal and a lot of funky features
and regular expressions like look
Ahead's look behind positive look
Ahead's and things like that and to
black back like a small step back so
what type x language grammar what does
it mean I'm talking of course I'm
talking about formal grammars and formal
languages and it's like the Chomsky
things and basically a grammar of 5x is
able to generate a language of type X
and the grammar simplified but usually
it's a set of terminals
that's like building blocks of your
language non terminals which are kind of
intermediate things and then there are
routes to transform these non terminals
into something else and the smaller the
X the rich of the language so type 2
languages are more powerful than types
reading which is what what we wanted to
here of course is not to generate
language but if we want to pass language
but that's basically just the inverse
problem right so if you if you have a
grammar for something then checking
where the sentence actually is part of
your language is in the end building up
the path tree and then if you have the
path tree you know how to interpret well
regular expressions they're very nice
for small pieces but as soon as things
get if you want to match complex more
complex stuff regular expressions tend
to get a bit clumsy I mean this one is
something that would
things like 1234 a.m. or p.m.
whatever but now I mean if you imagine
an expression that would also match at
Monday the 21st between 4:30 in the
morning and 15 o'clock in the afternoon
it will get very complex and very hard
to maintain so as an alternative one
could probably try to decompose the
problem so instead of building larger
and larger and larger regular
expressions what su time does in a sense
want to try to decompose the problem
into smaller problems so instead of
doing this thing on the top so like have
a look along or of all sorts of regular
expressions and this can be endless in a
way which then probably gives you a day
time just don't so if you see something
in your text that looks like a time and
smells like a time then why not just
assume that it is a time and take this
and try to combine with other things you
find in the text which in the sense
brings us to context-free grammars and
they're more expressive than the regular
expression let's type two languages and
instead of being able to produce things
where you have to produce some final
symbol followed up Tinley by non final
symbols they allow you to produce
arbitrary long sequences of terminals
and non-terminals and in for example UK
you could have rules in that language
which say add a time
what's anything that's a time plus
anything that's a date and then you can
specify various rules for how it can
look like a date well like the typical
day date date a month month year year
year thing or times per hour minute
minute well I mean what's positive about
context-free grammars they're more
expressive than regular expressions and
it's more compact in a way so it's
easier to navigate what you do on the on
the downside they can produce more all
right so they have more ambiguities
there multiple ways to power more more
ways to pass the same string to
different results well then there's no
standard Poisson model to handle there
and well when we even take that a step
further they're probabilistic
context-free grammars and it's actually
really small extension only saying that
every rule has a probability attached to
it which means you can then if you apply
a sequence of rules you can basically
multiply the probabilities and that
gives you a a the probability for your
production so the higher the probability
of your production the more likely
that's the correct one and also like
while you're searching for the solution
then you kind of use of course use these
probabilities to guide your search and
do a depth first search on the most
profitable path instead of widths first
search for vector City Pass is that a
pcfg and no it's not
but it's very similar the terminals and
pcfg are regular expressions so you have
a lot art we come to details a bit later
but you have a collection of your
regular expressions that basically
describe the building blocks of your
language anything that matches the
regular expression can in the end be
part of the production and non terminals
are the things we want to produce and
they actually just two times and
intervals but they are they are
parameterised so a time is basically a
container for possible partial x and we
get into details later so in a sense
there's unlimited potential non
terminals and a limited set of terminals
and then I don't know actually the last
line of my slide seems to be missing but
the rules are steroids so as a small
intermediate wrap-up interpreting time
expressions has many applications you
can do you can try regular expressions
if you have to deal with only metal well
for metal chance but things might get a
bit unmaintainable after a while using
probabilistic context-free grammars is
for very more intuitive more
maintainable and yeah there was no
patent advising package until not and so
how does the City Pass beast work
you know it gets a bit more dirty so as
I said there are basically two only two
types in City Pass one at a time and one
is an interval and in these types
everything is optional so the time is
really just the wrapper around the time
the time can be anything that is the
months August as a time or 2018 is the
time but then like Monday day of week
that's what do W stands for is the time
or expresses the time in p OD part of
day late afternoon could also be a time
and intervals are really just two pairs
of time and everything can be missing so
an interval can be left open or right
open or closed and well and the rules as
I said they are really just their
expressions saying that if you find
something that matches the matches
morning I mean that's like the most
simple rule you can think of probably
then you say okay then it's maybe a time
where the part of day is morning all the
roots say if you match a sequence of yet
and then something that is a time then
you just ignore the eight and say it's
still the same time right I mean if I
whether I say I want to meet at five or
five that doesn't change the time I'm
talking about if you know wonder where
the connection to the to the grammars is
you just have to read that the other way
around so what's returned here
that's the non terminal and the protti
the left-hand side and the right-hand
side of the productions is what's in the
rule thing right so it's basically says
the time can be a regular expression
morning or a time can be a regular
expression followed by something that's
a time so how do these rules work I mean
a way there can be regular expressions
it's probably the simple bit and other
than that the roots are the sequences of
regular expressions and intermediate
productions and the the rules refer to
properties of the intermediate
productions in CityPASS you can say you
can apply the rule if there is something
that is a time or you can apply apply
the rule if there is something that
it's a day of the week oh then you can
apply the rule if there's something that
has a year right so could have more but
at least you know that the time you
already passed knows what year it is and
then these rules are applicable if and
only if you can match the sequence of
these regular expressions and
productions like somewhere in your
intermediate production and then of
course if the production itself doesn't
fit I mean that's another thing that's
not part of context-free grammars but
the rules themself have a semantic right
if you want to produce a date from
something that's actually can't resolve
to date because it's like the 29th of
February 2018 which does not exist this
year then you can't produce that so from
that setup if you if you know think a
bit about it then ok all the terminals
are regular expression like everything
we can all the strings that the grammar
can produce or all the things that we
then can pass have to be regular
sequences of regular expressions in the
end if that's true then like a first
step one can do is we could just go in
all the rules collect all the regular
expressions match all these regular
expressions actually yeah and then
basically just see do we find sequences
of matching regular expressions that's
basically what I just said right so if
everything we can produce in the end is
the sequence of regular expressions
although you have to do in is basically
find all the matches of regular
expressions and then see which of them
make sense and which don't
so to make that a bit more goofy let's
let's pass the string July 8 2018 so
what city parts does first it takes all
the regular expressions from all the
rules and these numbers he actually
refer to actual expressions in the
library and just finds all matches of
them okay so in the string you can match
July as a month you can match just the
aid as
months or you can match eight as a day
of months and then 2018 can you can
either matches with which the regular
expression that's meant to match a year
or you can match it with a regular
expression that's meant to match a time
like 18 minutes past eight so once you
go to all these matches as we've seen
these matches they overlap right so the
m4 and m5 that just matched the same
text so there are multiple solutions
obviously and as we'd I mean fast it's
clear that this is a year but for the
machine of course it's not right and you
could even argue that July eights 2018
might refer to July 8th at 18 minutes
past 8 I mean pretty unlikely but so to
to keep that we now go and take all
these matches of regular expressions and
try to find all the sequences of these
regular expressions that do not overlap
and as it turns out for this example
there are three of them so you can you
can you can represent the sentence July
of the the bit July 8 2018 by three
different expressions three different
sequences of regular expressions as I
said once with the year and the end once
with the time and the third one actually
ends at the 8th because then there's
this unmatched bit of the th and then
there then it's over so and we just put
them all on a stick and then well we go
and apply productions so you take one
element from your stick and then you
test each rule can it be applied
somewhere in the sequence of this
intermediate productions and if so you
apply the production and produce a new
element that you put on the stick what
does it look like in a small example so
if you take the s2 which is happens to
be the correct one in the end that's the
sequence on the stick and then there's a
rule amongst July which just says if you
find the string July it's probably a
time where the month is
and then you produce well a new stack
element as for where you just replace
the expression that you matched by the
production and outreach time and time
months seven plus two regular
expressions that are still open and well
surprise surprise there's a rule that
matches the day of months and just says
okay if you see something like eights
then it's also a time it's the 8th day
of month and this gives you a new stack
which now basically says ok there's a
time which represents a month there's a
time which represents a day of months
and then there's still a regular
expression left and okay and they're
surprised again there's another rule
which says if you have months in the day
of a month then you probably mean the
day of that month and not of some months
right and then you'd say ok then you're
probably talking about aides of July and
then the rest is probably kind of use
you have an expression that says 2018
could be a year you put that on the
stack and then you have a rule that says
if you have a day off a year like the
AIDS of July without a year and a year
and this two together give you a more or
less full qualified date at least hope
ok that wasn't no P here there was
nothing probabilistic but that's
actually just a small Heckman in the end
right I mean you can just assume all
rules are equally probable and so for to
begin with and then I mean if you if you
if you've seen that then at each step of
the production there is a sequence of
the beginning this just the sequence of
regular expressions and then you apply a
sequence of rules on top of that
expression and if you just take the
names of these things this is basically
a sentence again and then if it's a
sentence and maybe you could do some
machine learning some NLP and try to
apply a model that tells you how likely
is this sentence like the sentence are
10 are 25 r9p 12 P 1 P 3 how likely is
this sentence to produce the correct
resolution in the end something that
actually the that is the thing you've
been looking for
I won't go into details here but what
city paths does vvv keep it simple and
it's just a naive Bayes classifier that
gets engrams over the sequences and then
there's asked to predict how likely is
the sequence to result in something
that's actually correct and yes I mean
if you do machine learning then
obviously you need some data to do
machine learning on and as in one part
of CT paths apart from all the the
algorithmic bits is is the rules and
then another part is something that's
called corpus and the corpus is
basically just a collection of input
strings plus the expected resolution of
this string so what what would what is a
correct way to interpret that string
then you can just take that data run it
through the system and check does the
system actually produce the right thing
and for all the paths where it's correct
you say okay this is the sequence that
will lead to the correct result for all
the pairs where you produce something
wrong you have a counter example and say
that's a negative software disadvantage
is that if you if you if you do
something in ct+ change your rule if you
add a rule if you modify something you
have to build this model again which is
it's part of the package and actually
it's important that the model matches
your rule set because otherwise if I
just predict produce put a predict
[ __ ] an advantage is that the this
also serves as a unit test right the you
have a big collection of samples on how
you expect your package to behave and
well if if you can't produce the correct
the resolution for anything in your
sample and something's wrong so how well
does that perform I mean the problem is
it's be difficult to compare and I mean
unless somebody disagrees and says no
there's package X Y that which excels at
interpreting time expressions there was
basically only duckling to compare
against and the comparison here is on
our internal data which is a set of
about 40,000 strings that Express time
and and someone took the burden to apply
labels to each of them and say okay this
string means
mm-hmm
yeah and well I mean City Pass seems to
perform quite well so it's um there are
two things you can ask see it's the
highest court solution is that one
correct or not and it's slightly better
than duckling the other thing you can
ask is is it able to produce correct
solution even though it probably doesn't
say that this is the most probable one
and there's that is even better than
duckling currently is and I mean we
don't use that too of the city parson
prank in our product yet but we will do
so within the next months and I could
imagine that this will get even better
so all theory is futile let's have a
quick sample here and actually I forgot
to restart this at work speed actually
now let's start from scratch just to
show that it actually works huh me it's
difficult to look it there and type here
so you can just import it and then you
ask it to pass something and that's what
you get right it says tomorrow it's the
8th of July and this is I mean it's
still in alpha mode so it gives you a
lot of information that you probably
won't need burtom the S means it's
caught with one point something and the
production was say ok you apply the
regular expression one five one and then
you apply the rule tomorrow due tomorrow
evening so then it says okay it still
AIDS of July then these xx means the
times are not specified and they are the
two exes and the brackets the first one
refers to the day of week which is not
given here but the second one to the
part of day in this tells you that the
string means something on the AIDS of
July in the evening and then it's
actually up to you to say what evening
is right and the production you also see
here it's like two matching regular
expressions and then three roots were
applied to get to that and let me try
something more complex twelve
2:15 ah I'm sure this is gonna fail you
know no it's actually not right so this
gives you an interval it's 2 times now
and basically the same thing as before
so it says it's from the first of July
to the 15th of July and just a bunch
more fruits yeah I mean if you want to
get it it's the usual way so right you
either clone the github repo or you do
pip install maybe you read the docs
which needs some improvement and now I
mean I hope you're so excited and can
you contribute yes you can of course
right I mean so forth basically our
internal effort to get that running and
improve it but and there's a lot of
things that can still be done I mean as
I said she compared that to duckling
duckling is much more flexible in what
it can parse it is not only handle times
and especially it handle its multiple
languages I didn't mention that's a city
parson spill to be language agnostic so
far it's only targeting German in
English and since German and English
apart from some actually one ugly detail
that's this the order of what's the day
and what's the month the expressions are
very similar you could easily be
extended to handle other languages like
I mean if you eat French then probably
you have really different ways to
express stuff or Chinese or whatever and
actually this day month thing is not a
big problem for City paths because as I
said in the beginning it's opinionated
about the kind of expressions you try to
pass so it's it's meant to pass things
that happen now not past the Bible and
reason about who was born or like
whatever Lord of the Rings and then try
to reason who was born when and was the
blood law of something it's really just
meant to say okay if you talk about time
now in real word which time could you
mean and this is usually in the future
right and then you can actually they're
very rare cast cases where it's not
clear what's the months and what's the
day
while speed could be optimized a lot of
rules which are still missing which we
know so there's many things one could do
so if you if you feel like it have a
look and have fun
[Applause]
are there any questions thanks yeah
thanks mom talk really interesting work
so I'm fighting with a very similar
housing tasks at work
and what I wanted to ask is twofold
first of all is there a tutorial
available how to define your own rule
sets and your own grammars no but I will
at one next week I actually thought it
would be clever to do that before the
presentation but it just didn't find the
time no problem it's actually quite
simple it's pretty cool and my second
question would be my colleague just
asked me like what happens if you have a
document that is written at a certain
time frame and says tomorrow is there
any way to tell the model or the the
parser what the context the time of the
context actually is I didn't show in the
small demo you usually have to pass in a
reference time so you can just you say
what is now and then everything is
interpreted relative to that now cool
thanks
thank you for the interesting talk the
German support the support for German
dates does that work out of the box
because I just looked at your
documentation and read the docs and I
couldn't find anything how to enable a
language in there do I just give it to
German text and it's fine yes I said it
currently it's language agnostic so I
mean that's it's basically practical
reasons what I mean like it come trouble
we basically only support German and
English messages so far and we have a
really big and a P pipeline to
understand what people ask for and in
most cases we actually figured out that
it doesn't really make a difference
whether we build two different models
one for German one for English or
whether we just build one model and
there's also holds true for the times to
a large extent so right now that's just
one set of rules that applies to German
in English and it doesn't really matter
but as I just mentioned like in the
future it would be easy and probably
useful to actually at least pass in the
language and say okay this text is
whatever in Korean and then either have
a separate set of rules to pass Korean
time expressions or have some way to
specify well to select a subset of the
rules or change the weights for example
right and say this is very common thing
in Korean but never appears in German so
if you already know it's Korean then you
might get different results right or
same thing German English day time today
in months order if you pass in the
information that this is English
probably even better that's British
English or American English because I
mean I don't know which is which right I
think the British actually do day months
and the American do month stay right and
then you of course could use that to
just pin down the correct solution so I
thanks for the talk um could you
I'm standing and could you talk a little
bit about what sort of cases it fails on
so you know the 32 percent where it gets
it wrong like what are those cases look
like mm-hmm there there's one type of
failure which is related to speed I
would say it has it has a built-in
timeout parameter which you can freely
set and there are you can easily you can
generate cases where if you don't set
that parameter it will just go on and on
and on and on and then maybe 20 minutes
later you get a response and I mean so
it needs a generator right so you get
the first response pretty quickly but it
will still just go on and on and on and
produce more and more and more
resolutions and I guess that could could
be helped by actually improving the
model that's in there because this naive
basis it's really naive and they're
probably also ways which are very more
clever than just looking at this
production sequence it doesn't mean it
doesn't look at all on like it says like
right now it really just says the
initial sequence of regular expressions
was this and then you applied these
rules in that order but it wants that
you also know to which expressions you
actually applied the rules so yeah it
doesn't look at the tree yeah and other
things I mean it does not handle typos
well actually not at all would be doable
on the REC X level you could just say
okay I allow some at a distance here and
the regular expression which but then on
the other hand it increases the number
of potential passes so it's a trade-off
here yeah and I mean it also like if you
if you pass and really not well
formatted strings that's also not very
advisable there's a small normalization
function baked in which should probably
go somewhere else because it should be
someone the user has to take care of but
if you if you have some funky UTF
characters that screws up all the magic
other than that I mean of course there
are as I said there are quite a few
rules we're not I'm be aware of that
they're missing but which pause is quite
a bit
hello I'm here yeah thanks for the talk
I've just one question
the you manufactured the rules and did
you think of a way to generate automatic
rules based on the the failures how
would you do that
something interesting idea but part of
my question yeah I mean their way so
what what what we try to do there's
nothing to do with the way we do it here
right there so there was a paper I
forgot by who they trained the trend
model to pass times right you give it a
string and then you discretize time by
whatever whatever you're willing to do
like say whatever half an hour buckets
and say okay whatever I try to predict
this within the next half an hour that
gives you something like two thousand
classes and then you try to classify the
strings into which bucket they belong we
tried that fails I didn't work well and
then automatically get rules no I
wouldn't know how to do that at least
not how to do meaningful rules is also
likely doing this roots is on the one
hand it's very easy you can just I mean
you see something that doesn't pass and
then you basically and just say okay
then let's write a regular expression
that would match that thing or match the
bit that doesn't get picked up and then
just try again but then there are a lot
of dependencies right then this rule
might also match things that you
actually don't want to match and produce
false positives or might increase the
search base unreasonably sometimes it's
really if you have small typos in a rule
if you if you happen to add a rule that
matches I don't know you miss type and
it matches a dash for itself then of
course this gives you a lot of more
unique sequences because you can
suddenly you can go and say okay there's
like initially there's another sequence
that could be in the initial stack which
matches the dash here and then there's
like ten routes which also match the
dash and then well the search pace
explodes but if you have any idea how to
do that
then let's talk hi thanks for the talk
I have a question there's a Python
package called pendulum I don't know if
you heard about it so it's used to sort
of parse daytime formant but not from
like generated language but more less
standardized so the question is have you
heard of it because I think you could
sort of use it as a first level to just
maybe the time trainees actually
standardized that would be easier to
extract it and if that doesn't work we
use like your solution I've heard of it
since it was not on this slide I forgot
about it yes I mean but again I mean if
I understood you correctly also say this
is mainly targeted as a well-formed
expression sound like the date you to
date processor if it if it looks like at
least like a well the way you would
write a date in a letter to your mother
then it will get it but if it's slightly
different it was not read in and of
course you can always just try to to to
check whether this matches some simple
regular expressions and then no need to
use a tool like this but I'm usually I'm
a lazy guy I mean if if you put in
something here that is not just a
typical way to write a time it's also
very very fast if it just take a few
milliseconds to give you a response
so I guess doesn't there's not really a
lot of use for that right another thing
that I mean that an issue we have here
with the times that said if people write
an email they're usually then don't
write an email and more often than not
they don't write an email and say okay I
need a flight and then they write a
proper date
in the time or something that all sets
together in a consecutive part of the
text but rather goes like I will fly to
London next week I need to be there at
Monday morning but not later than 10:00
and then all those pieces that actually
make up the time are scattered around in
the text and you get some noise in
between and we we just use some standard
entity tagger to find the pieces that
belong to time expressions but then if
you stitch them together
there's usually some noise in between
writing hi have you thought about
incorporating like a mutable timeline in
your expression so what I mean is you
can preset your your now you've said so
but what if the speaker kind of resets
that for you so let's say that I want to
say I took drug X for 3 months 2 years
ago yeah I know it's like I'm just
asking depends on what you wanted
library to focus on right I mean this
library it's at least currently as it
stands the focus is not to do that level
of reasoning it's really on that level
like you have identified a piece of text
or you say that is a time expression I
just want to know what it means and then
if you have these scenarios where you
really have to reason and the in the in
the bigger context of the text like
because well time moves back and forth
like the the reference time and the text
move specs and they can force that would
need to be handled externally I guess it
would be very difficult to do right I
mean it's like not very difficult cuz
that approaches to do it but I guess you
have a trade-off between saying I'm
either very precise on these small
snippets or you're able to handle these
more complex relations between different
time expressions and a longer text but I
get my person the feeling would be
that's better handled outside of the
thing that tries to understand a little
bit in what we do is like if we read
these messages we start at the message
date when we when we receive the message
and then like let's say we hit the first
we hit the first time and we also know
let's let's say we also know that this
refers to the departure time of some
flight and then once we pass that time
we advance the reference time and say
okay anything that happens afterwards at
least like if then the next thing the
person asks for is a hotel it's relative
to the or the once a return flight is
relative to the departure time
don't want the return flight before the
outbound flight right but this is really
just heuristics which are very specific
to our case any more questions
since Thank You minutes early we don't
want to stop two minutes early right
I actually I was just wondering how you
arrived at this particular design or
architecture and what are the things
that you tried that didn't work I wonder
what are the things that you tried that
didn't work what we tried that didn't
work
like rather than this particular sort of
bad setup Thanks
well I mean we tried all the libraries I
mentioned and I mean so far we actually
just used duckling which is really
painful but yeah and then well this
classification approach we try to put
well other than that we just spend time
on this and hope to get this to a point
I mean it's already it's already at a
point where we can make use of it and
and I think there's quite a bit of
potential
[Applause]